PROFESSOR: So now, let's start
talking about airborne disease
transmission, thinking
especially of viral diseases
where we expect the
transmission to occur
through aerosol droplets or
at least smaller droplets,
which may sediment
but are going to be
suspended in the air for a
significant amount of time.
So the first approximation
of such a situation
is to assume a
well-mixed room, meaning
that the air in the
room is well mixed.
And even if there is, let's
say, one person who's infected
and that infected person is
breathing, talking, singing,
respiring, and exhaling
infected aerosol droplets,
then these droplets start
to spread around the room.
And they do so
because the room is--
and we assume that the
room is well mixed.
So even though,
as I've sketched,
there's certainly going to
be a higher concentration
of the droplets near the
infected person, that
is there are significant
airflows in the room, which
induce mixing.
That is partly driven
by the flow of fresh air
through the room.
Typically, we may have
some forced ventilation
coming through ducts with fans.
There could be open windows.
And even when a
room is not open,
meaning that the windows
are closed, maybe even
the door is closed,
there's always
some leakage and exchange of
air with the outside, which
typically happens on
the order of hours.
So there's always at least
some kind of flow rate.
Also, there's a movement
of people in the room,
and there's also breathing
itself, which basically
imparts momentum to
the fluid and causes
swirling motions of the fluid.
So the situation actually
is more like this
where there's these flows
that are generated either
by the ventilation,
by the movement
and respiration of the
people, also by thermal flows.
So when you're breathing, the
air coming out of your lungs
is warmer, and
that tends to rise.
But, also, if it's very
humid air and very warm air,
then actually the weight of
all the humidity and droplets
that come with
air could actually
cause some settling as well.
So you have all these
different processes going on.
And your first
approximation, just
assume that those lead to
a well-mixed situation.
And so we will proceed to
analyze disease transmission
from that assumption,
and then we'll
come back at the
end to consider what
would happen if there
are actually fluctuations
and think about the distance
from an infected person
and how that might play
a role in departures
from the predictions of
a well mixed room.
OK.
So defining some
variables, then.
We'll let C of t
be the, basically,
infectiousness of
the air, if you will.
But more specifically,
if we think of virus,
it'll be the virions
per air volume.
So they're contained
in droplets.
And later we will consider
what size droplets
they may be contained
in, but for now, let's
just average over
everything and say there's
some concentration in the air.
We have a production rate of
these infectious droplets,
which can be broken
down into many terms.
So this is the
production rate, so this
is the number of virions
per time that are produced.
So that would be Qb is
our breathing flow rate.
So that's basically the volume
of exhaled air per breath
cycle, so that's how much
air is being pushed out
in your breathing.
And this is typically--
ranges from 0.5 up to around
3 meters cubed per hour.
So 0.5 is a typical
resting breathing rate.
And, in fact, even
if you're just
kind of calmly speaking and
sitting in a room breathing
through your nose, that'll be
your typical breathing rate.
But if you start exercising
and start exerting yourself,
then that could go
up to maybe around 3.
And so that's the typical
range of the breathing rate.
The next thing we need is Nd
is the droplet concentration,
so this is the number
of drops per air volume.
So that's sort of the
number density of drops.
So if I have various
visualization techniques,
I can actually see all the
droplets, and I can count them.
I can say how many droplets
are in a given volume.
The next thing is I need
the volume of a drop.
So as I mentioned,
of course there
are different drop
volumes, and we'll
come back to assessing the
effects of a droplet size
distribution.
But for simplicity,
why don't we just take
these sort of average size
drops that we discussed
coming from respiration,
And that might be a number
around 1 micron in size.
And there's a volume that
corresponds with that, which,
of course, is the
4/3 pi r cubed where
we assume for now only one
size r for all drops just
for the moment.
So now we have the
volume here, so now
we sort of what is the
total amount of drops.
So the next thing
we need now is Cv.
Cv will be the number of virions
per liquid volume or per drop
volume, so there's certain-- so
if I could take the pure liquid
in the drop-- let's
say it's mucus--
and it's been coming
out of your pharynx
and has sort of fragmented and
taken some virions with it,
then that would be the
viral load, essentially.
Sometimes that's
another word for this.
And the viral load
varies with time.
So when you first get infected,
at first the viral load
is very low in the fluids
that you're breathing out.
And then that raises up.
And during the period when
you're most infectious,
which for COVID-19
and SARS-CoV-2 virus,
that time ends up being
around a week or so when you--
well, within a few days, you
reach the peak infectiousness.
And then when you're
at the peak viral load,
this ends up being about
10 to the ninth virions
per milliliter of
fluid when you're
at your peak infectiousness
for SARS-CoV-2.
OK.
So just to give you a sense,
but of course, a lot of times
it might be less than that.
But if you're very
infected individual,
that's kind of a worst case.
And we're going to be
interested in calculating
safety guidelines and
probabilities of transmission,
so to be conservative,
it's good to have
an idea of how big this
number can actually be.
So what we just
calculate here-- so,
basically, this Nd, Vd
is the amount of drop
or liquid volume per air
volume, so that's essentially
the volume fraction of liquid.
When we go times Cv,
we're essentially
getting the number of virions
in the air per volume of air.
And then Qv is the
volume per time,
so this is basically
virions per time.
And then one other factor
that we should also
consider is what
if we're actually
filtering those droplets
right at the source?
And that'll be the case
if you're wearing a mask.
So this is an important
quantity we'll come back to.
This will be the mask
penetration probability
for a droplet.
So this is-- of course
is size dependent,
but we'll come back to that.
But for the moment, we're just
saying it's one drop size.
And so for the size of drops
of interest, we're asking,
do they go through the mask?
So 1 minus Pm is also called
the filtration efficiency.
Yes.
So a very good mask might be
99% of droplets are filtered.
A very poor cloth
covering might be
10% of droplets are
filtered, and we'll come back
to that in just a moment.
So this here is our
production rate capital P.
And already with the variables
that we've written down here,
we can write down a mass
balance for the virions.
So virions are being produced.
They end up in these droplets.
The droplets are being swept out
of the room at a flow rate Q,
and the room has a volume
V. So if I write down
just the conservation of
mass, making sure that I'm not
losing any virus yet--
I'm not allowing them
to stick to the walls
or do anything else
just yet but just
looking at the mass balance of
one infected person breathing
out.
This is, I should say,
production rate per infector,
or an infected person.
So if there are more
infected people,
then you'll have this
production rate for each person.
They also might be at
different stage of the disease,
so maybe the viral
load will be a little
different for each person.
But let's not worry about
such details right now.
We want to keep things general.
So for the mass
balance, we write down
the total number of
virions in the room
and how that changes in time.
So that'll be the concentration
per room air volume, which
is well-mixed times the
volume of the room per time.
So this is the change in the
number of virions per time,
and that can change in two ways.
One, we have the production P.
So for every infected person,
we have production
P, but this will be--
I should say virions per
air volume per infector.
So if we want to think about
having multiple infected people
in the room, we can always
just basically increase
this concentration.
A well-mixed room, it doesn't
matter where people are placed.
You're just getting
more and more droplets,
and it's assumed to be mixed.
So we produce at a rate P,
but then the outdoor flow
is taking away
droplets and, hence,
removing virions at a rate
Q. So we have a Q times
C removal rate.
So this is our equation.
So let's divide through by V.
So we can write this
as dC dt is P/V minus,
and then Q/V I'll
write as lambda a C.
So lambda a, which is Q/V,
this is the outdoor air change
or exchange rate.
So that is the rate at which
the entire volume of the room
is replaced with outdoor air.
So the outdoor air
is refreshing the air
in the room at
this rate Q/V. OK.
And so that's what appears here.
And if you compare these two,
you can see that this is dC dt.
This is C times lambda, so
lambda is units of 1 over time.
It's a t.
This is also sometimes called--
the ACH is air changes per hour
if you write it in per hour.
So that's a typical way
that this is written.
And, in fact, while
we're just talking about,
this is a very
important concept.
So lambda a is around 0.3 per
hour, so roughly every 3 hours
for a closed room.
So closed room or what you might
call natural ventilation where
there's no attempt to
deliver air to that room.
Of course, this number
depends on the tightness
of the construction and whether
there is cracks in the windows,
whether doors are being
opened to the hallway.
So, of course, that's
not a perfect number,
but that's a rough estimate
how quickly air is escaping
from typical construction.
But then it can be, also,
in a different range.
And this a very important
parameter for the theory,
so let's pause just to look
at some of the numbers.
So it's in the range--
it's typically 3 to 8
per hour for
mechanical ventilation.
So this could be--
it could be open windows
with fans blowing in and out,
which might give you 3
or even 6 on this number.
It could also be a
ventilation system,
which is delivering
fresh air to the space.
And for typical classrooms,
offices, and even homes,
this is a typical range.
So for example, if
it's 3, then that
would be every 20 minutes
the room gets its air
to be fully exchanged.
But of course, if
you have situations
where you need to have
better air quality
and you have more risk
of, say, transmission
of disease or passage of
pollutants or contaminants,
then we need higher values.
A typical number in the
United States for hospitals
is 18 air changes per hour.
And then it can be even larger.
So if you have a
laboratory, which
is dealing with toxic
chemicals or even,
let's say, virus and
pathogens, then you
need even higher air changes.
And typical rates, then,
can be as high as 20 to 30
for labs that are dealing
with toxins of various types
because--
and any airborne toxins
have to be quickly removed
so that if they
happen to be leaked
into the air from your
experiment or from your hood,
they need to be
quickly sucked out.
Also, even parking
lots where you
have cars in an enclosed space
that are generating carbon
monoxide and other fumes, which
have to be quickly rushed out,
parking lots tend to have
this number around 30.
So that's a full air change of
the entire room in 2 minutes.
That's a very fast flow rate.
So this is kind of the
range of this lambda a.
That's, obviously, a
very important parameter.
So let's now solve
this equation here.
So, first of all, you
can see when dC dt is 0,
then the steady state is
just P over lambda a V.
But if I write Q
equals lambda a V,
I can see the steady
state is just P/Q.
So I can write the
solution like this--
that if we're given time
dependence, that the P/Q is
the steady state.
And if I started out with
my initial condition,
was that C of 0 equals 0.
So let's say time equals 0 is
when the infected person enters
the room and starts breathing.
And then there's
a mixing process
and there's a build-up
of concentration
until there's a balance between
the production of virus,
virions, or infectious air and
the removal of infectious air
by the ventilation.
And that gives you this ratio
P/Q. But the way the relaxation
happens, though--
if you balance these
two terms here,
that's just an exponential
decay with a decay rate lambda
a, so e to the minus lambda a t.
So this is basically the way
the concentration builds up.
If I plot this, then at a
certain time here, which
is sometimes called Tres--
in chemical engineering,
these kinds of models
are commonly used to
design chemical reactors.
In fact, this kind of model
is in chemical engineering
called a continuous
stirred-tank reactor.
We don't worry
about the details,
but we have a flow
of some reactants
and various chemical
species going into a tank.
We assume it's well
mixed and then it leaves,
and this is the mass
balance that we use.
And the residence time,
Tres, is the inverse
of lambda a in this case.
So that is the--
as soon as you know the volume
and the ventilation flow rate,
there's a typical speed
going through here.
And the time that
fresh air spends
in the room interacting with
all the droplets and people
and then leaving, carrying some
of those droplets, is this.
And in a simple model
like this, it's just
an exponential relaxation at
that time scale approaching
the steady state, which is P/Q.
So there's always that kind
of balance which is reached.
Now let's also ask
ourselves, briefly at
this point, how reasonable is
the well-mixed approximation?
We will come back to this and
analyze it much more carefully,
taking into account all the
different processes I described
at the beginning, including
breathing, motion of people.
But let's just think about the
motion caused by the airflow
itself.
So in the case of
mechanical ventilation
where that flow rate can
be sometimes rather high,
that can be a significant
source of mixing in the system.
And the way we'll
think about that
is by writing down the
typical velocity of the air
due to the outdoor air flow.
That is Q. We can write it as
either Q divided by the area,
so some kind of representative
area of the room.
It could be, let's
say, the floor area,
but depending on the
shape of the room,
it might be a little bit
different value than that.
We can also write this as
Q times H over V, where
V is the volume
of the room and H
is some characteristic height,
like, for example, a ceiling
height of the room.
OK.
So this is the mean
airspeed due to ventilation.
And we'll come back to a
more deeper investigation
of these fluid
mechanics of the room.
But as a first example of what
we'll be interested in is we'd
like to calculate the Reynolds
number due to the airflow.
So I'll put a subscript a there.
And that is the typical velocity
times a length scale, which
could be, let's say,
the height of the room
or some linear length
scale of the room,
depending on the
direction of the airflow.
And then the kinematic
viscosity of air,
so I'll write that as new a.
So this here is the
Reynolds number.
This is basically telling us how
important inertia of the fluid
is compared to viscous stresses
that slow the fluid down.
So, basically, it
tells us how quickly--
how much of a tendency
there is for momentum
to be carried in the
fluid, which then
leads to sort of swirling
motions and complex flows,
as I've sketched here.
And this new a is the
viscosity of the air
that we've already talked about
when looking at Stokes flow
but divided by the
density of the air.
OK.
So that's the
kinematic viscosity.
And for air, the
kinematic viscosity
is 1.5 times 10 to the minus
5 meters squared per second.
And so if I plug these
numbers in and I pick,
let's say, a typical ceiling
height of maybe a few--
I think this-- if the H
is of order 3 meters--
or 2 meters might
be a typical scale.
Just to get an approximate
sense of the scale here,
the Reynolds number will be
varying from around 50 or tens,
up to 5,000, which would
be in the case of very fast
ventilation like the 30 ACH.
So this would be if we have
0.3 ACH up to around 30 ACH.
That's just a rough number.
And from fluid
mechanics, we know
the significance of these
large Reynolds numbers
is that the flows really do
look a bit like I've shown here.
So, basically, when the air
is sitting in the room--
you know this from
looking at the smoke
from a candle or other flows
that you can visualize--
it's not just a sort
of uniform flow.
But instead there are all
these sort of plumes and swirls
and vortices.
And when the Reynolds number
is on the order of tens,
when there is a motion,
it tends to lead
to a shedding of a vortex and
to some kind of swirling flows.
And when the Reynolds
number gets up as high
as several thousand,
then in most geometries
that starts to lead to a
transition to turbulent flow.
And that's when
the flow is getting
so complicated there are
eddies of different sizes
and very rapid mixing.
So I just wanted
to show this right
at the beginning
of the discussion
to point out that
for typical flows
we would expect
that there is going
to be a decent amount
of mixing occurring just
because of the ventilation.
And now if you add to the fact
that people are breathing,
imparting momentum
to the fluid, we
have people moving and other
kinds of activities in a room,
that all of those
processes lead to giving us
a reasonable assumption
of a well-mixed room.